[Music]
so
[Music]
coming up on fyi in a special report we
head to one of the largest refugee camps
to meet the world's youngest peace
campaigner banner alabed that makes me
really upset seeing children living in
tents it's just not right
as the world focuses on helping
ukrainians banner appeals for us not to
forget millions of children who have
fled other wars
[Music]
welcome to your weekly news show fyi
before our special report we're going to
celebrate girl power and sport
firstly of course congratulations to the
england team who brought football home
with their massive win in the women's
euro championships the football
association says that their win means
there'll be much better opportunities
for all girls who want to play football
i just had to get hold of superfan tests
he went viral with footage of her
celebrating a goal at the semi-final
hi tess how are you good
so after you went viral the england team
gave you tickets to see the final at
wembley was that really fun for you yeah
it was amazing and the atmosphere was
great because where we were sat was like
in the middle but like slightly to the
right right and chloe kelly's goal and
ella teams goal was amazing do you play
football
yes
recently i went for a trial for leeds
united and i got into one of the
emerging talent centers in leeds would
you ever want to play for england one
day yeah that that's one of my like
things that i want to do when i'm older
yeah i think you definitely will thanks
tess bye
it's such an exciting summer for sport
in our country as well as the euros
we've had wimbledon now the commonwealth
games in birmingham and there was
another sport event on our coast
the stale grand prix is described as the
most exciting race on water scarlet went
to plymouth to meet hannah mills
britain's most successful sailor to
check it out
[Music]
is sail gp a high-speed sailing race
with boats that literally fly across the
water
[Music]
this is the f50 a bow so powerful and
fast it can reach speeds of up to 60
miles per hour
hannah mills is the most successful
female sailor in olympic history and now
she races for great britain in the sale
gp championship
what type of skills does it take to make
it go so fast to go fast i guess
everyone in the boat has their
individual role that's very different i
guess from each other so obviously the
driver is the driver you know i'm
calling the wind and the race course
which way we want to go then there's the
guy that's doing the the flight controls
yep you heard right these boats really
do fly
and it's all down to these blades called
hydrofoils
so these are the hydrofoils yes so these
are the things under the boat that make
the boat fly out the water and get to
the speeds that we can get to but when
we go sailing they come up and down and
they go down sort of two two and a half
meters so that's how high the boat is
flying out the water and you can kind of
see the shape you know they're kind of
shaped like a wing obviously they're
pointing inwards rather than outwards
that you'd imagine an airplane but it
does the same thing i then got to see
hannah and the team in action on their
first practice day in plymouth
they're going so fast and flying through
the water because of the hydrofoils
underneath the boat
that was so cool i mean i felt like we
were flying through the water i mean i
looked over and they were like running
from one side it was so exciting they
were like skimming across the top
and it's great to see the teams are a
mix of men and women
cell gp hope to inspire the next
generation of young female sailors like
catty rogers who came up through their
youth program just last year and has
already got to sail with team gb
the cell gp program has developed the
women's pathway program which is trying
to close the gap between male and female
athletes
so it's basically trying to give female
athletes more time on the water and just
equal opportunities basically it's
amazing now you're here to inspire other
young people like yourself well that's
the aim for sure sadly it wasn't a win
for team gb this time but it was great
to see them in action
[Music]
here at fyi we discuss the big issues
with the kids who are affected by them
we call it conversation
when i say refugees what do you think of
ukrainians fleeing the war right
but charities are appealing to us not to
forget the millions of other refugees
who have fled from other wars and are in
terrible conditions
so we're gonna head to one of the
world's largest refugee camps for a
special report
[Music]
my name is bana i'm 13 years old and i
live in turkey but this isn't where i'm
from
my home city is aleppo in syria
sadly my happy childhood was torn apart
by wall
as the bombs fell around my home
[Music]
my mom and i reached out to the world
using social media to let people know
what was happening
so many people saw my messages
it changed my life forever
[Music]
the first time i got to know what was
going on in syria was when i saw
banner's videos posted online i remember
being really worried about what would
happen to her
especially after she told the world that
her best friend yasmin had been killed
in a bomb attack
i am sad
so bad
it was way too dangerous for banner and
her family to stay in syria
so they fled to turkey where they became
refugees
but bannon wasn't like any other refugee
her social media posts had caught the
attention of millions of people
including the turkish president richard
type erdogan
wanting to show the world his kindness
he arranged a safe home for her and her
family thank you
sadly not all refugees have been made to
feel as welcome as banner was
many syrian families ended up living in
terrible conditions in refugee camps
so banner decided to use her global fame
to demand better treatment of refugees
i'm about to have a conversation with a
girl determined to change the world a
girl who is campaigning for the one
thing that would end the suffering of
millions of kids
peace
[Music]
the first time i met banner was back in
2019
my job was to introduce her at a
conference in dubai as she gave a speech
to celebrities and world leaders
your excellencies
ladies and gentlemen please welcome to
the stage banner
alibaba
her message was that refugees should be
able to live with dignity and children
who've had to flee their countries
should still be able to go to school
they want to be teachers they want to be
doctors but without education they want
to be anything
even though we live in different
countries fanner and i have become
friends and today we're meeting up in
jordan brayden hi hello how are you i'm
very well thank you bana how are you i'm
good
but we haven't come to jordan just for a
catch-up banner has asked me here
because she wants to show me why her
campaign to help refugees is still so
desperately needed
we're on our way to a place called
zachary the largest syrian refugee camp
in the world
it's just six miles from the border with
syria
so britain have you ever been to a
refugee camp before no i haven't and to
be honest with you i'm not really sure
what to expect okay
this place opened ten years ago and it
was just a hundred of tents in the
desert and it was just meant to be
temporary but now it's home to over 80
000 people and more than half of them
are children
the saturday refugee camp is huge it's
like a city in the middle of the desert
and this is the main street
it's not what i was expecting at all
so brandon what are your first
impressions then well for me it just has
to be the size of this place i mean it's
massive and i think it is a little bit
overwhelming and to think none of this
was here 10 years ago i feel like a
temporary solution has almost become an
obvious permanent exactly i mean just
look at this street this has become a
proper shopping street and i've heard
people have been calling it the
champs-elysees which is one of the [ __ ]
shopping streets in paris it's a joke
look around you can pretty much buy
anything here bicycles food
even phones wow i know and wedding
dresses
isn't that crazy people getting married
here i mean i want one i mean even
though we are in a refugee camp it's
almost like everybody's just getting on
with their everyday lives and trying to
make the best out of a bad situation
to find out what life is like for the
refugees here we're meeting a family
with six children
they came here in 2012 to escape the war
and have been here ever since
so why was it so important for you and
your family to leave syria and come here
surya can't be haram in syria there was
a war and no safety
if we'd have stayed in syria there would
have been no safety at all
we came to jordan because the jordanians
are kind people
so what are your hopes for the future
it's been there no i hope to continue my
studies outside the camp and outside of
jordan and succeed and learn english
hello what are your hopes for the future
and where do you want to go
[Music]
i want to leave and not stay here
i want to leave to a european country
there is no future here
and can you please tell me what is the
best thing about living in a camp and
what is the worst thing
the best thing
there is nothing
and the worst thing
is that we are living here
that's what she is the worst thing is
the dust
[Music]
most of the people live like this
basically
metal containers
i mean even though the families are
trying to make it like a proper home and
have that warmth to it i just can't get
my head around how difficult it must be
to come to a completely different place
and have none of your stuff yeah when
you become a refugee you can only take
what you can carry i still remember when
i had to leave syria i couldn't take my
dolls i was really upset
this looks quite basic but you know it
can be a lot worse
not far from the family's home there's a
community centre where children can come
and meet their friends log onto laptops
and get involved in all sorts of
activities i'm meeting two girls who
come here every day so can you remember
how old you were when you first came to
the camp
i was three years old and i came
and there were tents but things have
changed a lot since then
life has changed
and instead of tents
they're in our caravans
you can do whatever you want now
it is much better than it used to be
with possibilities to study
are you allowed to you know leave the
camp sometimes and then come back what
is the freedom like i started
if you have permission then you can come
and go as you like
but there are police and security on
if we go and get permission for a
holiday
for say a week
and stay out of the camp for longer than
that
then we won't be allowed back in
many of the refugees dream of a day when
they can return to their homeland and
live in peace
but syria's civil war has been going on
for more than 11 years now with
different groups fighting over who
should have control of the country
more than half a million syrians have
been killed and more than 13 million
people have fled their homes to seek
safety
most of them come to neighboring
countries like turkey where banner lives
or jordan
for its part the uk is taking in around
20 000 syrian refugees
[Music]
some syrian people are so desperate that
they try to get into the uk on small
boats crossing the english channel from
france
but some people think they shouldn't be
allowed to stay here
back in jordan about 80 percent of
syrian refugees live outside the
official camps but with very little
support many of them struggle with
extreme poverty and it can be especially
dangerous for children
[Music]
you know it makes me really upset seeing
children living in tents it's just not
right it makes me feel really guilty
that i have a proper house and a great
school
but at the same time i'm trying my best
to highlight about the syrian refugees
lately the ukrainian people have been
getting a lot of help this is just a
great thing but people shouldn't also
forget about refugees around the world
it's time for us to leave
we've seen for ourselves just how
difficult life can be for syrian
refugees but at the same time we've seen
how there are also moments of happiness
for the children who live here
people aren't just around feeling sorry
for themselves they're doing the best
they can to make things better
and maybe one day with the help of
charities and campaigners like banner
they'll be able to live a normal life in
a place they're proud to call their home
[Music]
join in on the big conversation about
racism poverty conflict and war and how
we are affected for more conversations
head to sky kids on demand or our
webpage first.news fyi just hit the link
see you next time